a nationwide operation targeting
thousands of undocumented migrant
families will reportedly begin Sunday
the New York Times says raids are
expected to take place in at least ten
major cities
they'll be conducted by immigration and
customs enforcement Omar Villafranca is
in Dallas are me Omar what do we know
about what's gonna happen well good
morning Isis reportedly targeting about
2,000 immigrants who are in the country
illegally and have been ordered deported
the agency is also saying that they're
traditionally focusing on those with a
criminal history but any immigrant who's
violating US law could be arrested
they'll be sorry fairly soon
president Trump renewed his threat last
Friday to order mass deportations of
undocumented migrant families the raids
were postponed in June after the
president previewed the operations on
Twitter stating ice would remove
millions of illegal aliens the raids
have been a flashpoint in immigrant
communities across the country the
so-called raids it's its interior
enforcement we do it every day CBS News
spoke with acting Customs and Border
Protection Commissioner mark Morgan
about the agency's plans in an interview
last month if you're a mother with a kid
is that mother gonna be handcuffed no
she doesn't need to be handcuffed but if
you're a criminal alien and you've been
convicted of murder sexual assault and
etc are you gonna be handcuffed you bet
you're gonna be handcuffed the possible
raids come amid increasing scrutiny over
conditions at migrant detention centers
on Wednesday
reporters toward a new HHS facility for
children in Carrizo springs Texas video
shows clean rooms and children in
classrooms which contrast troubling
images from a recent DHS inspector
general's report that condemned
unsanitary conditions and dangerous
overcrowding at some CBP facilities in
an emotional hearing Wednesday
yasmine Juarez said she blamed unsafe
conditions and poor medical care at a
nice detention center in Dili Texas for
the death of her one-year-old daughter
Maddie a lawmakers were visibly shaken
by her testimony
were brought to tears it's like they
tore out a piece of my heart she said
like they tore out my soul what are the
groups getting a lot of attention
unaccompanied migrant children in the US
officials actually told us yesterday
there's about 200 in CBP custody that's
down from about 2,500 back in May Tony
oh my thank you we'll stay on top of it